all right randall
randall where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
rural appalachia which part
uh north carolina
so the western part of north carolina
yep
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad mm-hmm yeah um
father's a pastor
grew up in a pentecostal church
and uh
mom was secretary
of the church
and for a number of years she did some
of that work there's also private school
built into the church
as i was growing up
um
father played a role in
administration there
and um my mom was also a kindergarten
teacher
as part of a
school section of that how would you
describe your childhood in general
um
good in the sense that i was able to
get out into the woods with my dog
and play and explore
um
i was able to appreciate like those
simple things
um
i have a sister that's three years older
than me we would um play outside
um
great for the imagination
communication was pretty indirect with
my parents created a lot of tension
they had
some trauma from their childhood they
were working
with they had the best they could
um
and
i developed some dysfunction i think
within that
tension um
eventually
uh
kind of developed this sort of emotional
overload where i would seize
it's
known as like
pnes psychogenic non-epileptic seizures
which is connected in some ways
sometimes with people that also have
seizures i'm not epileptic but
if i pass out i have a seizure anyways
and then in my teens i was like a goth
kid this loner goth kid in town
so growing up in the church was a
pastor's son there was a lot of pressure
there and um
i was fine trying to find my place you
know i was kind of in nobody's corner in
that way
um
[Music]
so i had to kind of find my own way
um
[Music]
and as i got older in my teens
i was hit with really heavy depression
uh from 17
moving into college
um
i was reclusive at one point or i
couldn't even make eye contact with
people
and
um the pnes episodes were happening
still
um and i became suicidal
um
so i'd say at like 1819 i was prepared
to take my life
bordering in between those years of my
age
to where i was just like a hollow shell
walking around and um
i'd have like shivers down my spine the
whole day i was just that like
disembodied almost where do you think
that came from
um
i
i hated myself
and i think that there was a perplexity
that schwartz kind of short-circuited me
in the sense that i couldn't like please
anybody um in my mind
and my like secluded
conscience
[Music]
so it put me at odds
i think that was part of
it um and i had to navigate through that
i just kind of boiled down to some
existential questions
why even live
[Music]
and
i so i kind of like you know
quote-unquote found god through
the back door of not uh
finding god through the church per se
but um through existential questions and
building out from that
um i'm like a christian existentialist
uh i agree with a lot of like
kierkegaard and um i'm only just
beginning to
learn about other existentialists but i
developed my own like
core philosophical axioms
so um
that was uh life-changing alongside that
i was actually beginning to read the
bible in a different light from a
different perspective not from this like
kind of prescribed
fast food western christianity you're in
the bible belt yeah in the bible though
right
um
and um you know music's played a huge
role too like in my
sense of connection
and worship and
artistic expression
um i have a graphic design background
that's what i went to college for
so i uh pushed myself out of my small
town it was growing up it was like
35 000 in the county
and um
3 500 in the town pretty rural
um i was kind of losing my mind so
alongside those pnes episodes i was i
was determined to get out so i
um played drums for a friend's band
overseas in norway
um
that was the turning point in a lot of
ways i self-taught in norwegian
uh fluent and um
i
later after developing relationships
worked with a non-profit
to then move there um
so then um i was searching for jobs to
say long term
uh but it proved to be extremely
difficult
so i made my way to san francisco
where i knew one person from a previous
job in north carolina
um
i was still dealing with some of those
episodes and heavy depression
um
but i was not um self-harming like i had
in my teens i was like
cutting myself burning myself in the
shower
asphyxiating that kind of thing
um
and i moved past that you know through
some of those uh
life-changing points where my paradigm
shifted
um so at least
i was able to cope
um a little better
but it was it was an overload for me it
was like a culture shock um because i
had never lived in like a big city
before
so
uh
yeah i mean that period was
absolutely the lowest point i had had a
family member i was close to that took
their life as well
while i was in um
well we we spent time together while i
was in college
right and that happened during my time
living in san francisco
so i mean it definitely impacted me
was this this is before antidepressants
were prescribed things like that
i was uh
iffy about taking into antidepressants i
heard so many stories of people having
difficulties tapering off
um from antidepressants that had kind of
um
locked them down and i felt like i could
manage myself well enough
probably the pastor's son and me
could like fake my way through seeming
like i was well enough
in front of other people
um
so i didn't tour with antidepressants
plus money i mean i didn't have i wasn't
on health insurance all these years i
hadn't been able to afford it
and
eventually
so i moved to colorado
basically started
starting over i started over three times
in norway
san francisco and then i knew zero
people in colorado moving out and um
which is where i live now
i had no job and no place to live
uh so i started from
staying
sleeping in the back of my truck
job hunting sun up to sundown
um i ended up landing in the lap of like
a psychopathic boss
for a delivery job at the time
um
i was riding um
[Music]
uh steel mesh exposed tires down an 85
mile per hour highway working 12 to 15
hour days
for 500 a week
um i was on tonal burnout and
but i found a good place to stay
with a lady that cared about me and we
became very good friends
so i figured whatever job i needed to
get that's what i would do
so i
i pushed myself through that misery for
three months which felt like an eternity
until i eventually just absolutely quit
when i quit
my boss actually quit too
i was holding down like more than a
two-person job
of the workload
um
like miraculously i pulled over on my
route
someone looking to buy the route spotted
me
and
was gonna take me on
so
that slipped through the cracks but he
passed me on to someone he knew that
could take me on which has been one of
the best work situations i've ever been
in now
um
so that was kind of the
the rough and tumble of jumping into
colorado
and um
it's very difficult starting from
absolute zero
in the sense that
you take for granted all the
acquaintances that you have and that you
build up from um
so
that in itself was such a pressure point
um holding all these things together
so psychologically the pnes episodes
were
recurring
uh and i got counseling
i i reached a point where i i said to
myself well i'm not figuring this out on
my own
i'm uh i'm over 30 years old this isn't
getting better
um so i did counseling and um
therapy help
it did tremendously um
like i'm an advocate on that for
everyone that i bump into at this point
um
because i was introspective
i could see
my flaws well enough
i could figure out how to hold things
together well enough
but
it gave me uh
a perspective to anchor from
with enough consistency
that helped pull me out of that it took
the right trust too i had to go through
it wasn't until my third counselor that
i stuck with
that made a really big difference um
i i've also had high social anxiety to
the point of passing out if i pass out i
have a seizure
so that was a problem in each of the
places that i lived that would have to
disappear into a closet so it wouldn't
pass out
so
counseling helped me manage all of that
in an entirely different way
um
[Music]
the third counselor landed on happened
to have like similar music taste he
liked joy division and all these other
great bands that meant like specifically
a lot to me
and i think he used that as an inroad to
gain my trust
and then i realized he actually cared my
problem was
i figured with counselors when the money
stops the counseling stops they don't
really care what can they do to help um
especially the concepts of like
love yourself was like never enough for
me to for instance not entertain the
idea of taking my life
but it was pulling that perspective
uh that changed everything
and and maintaining a consistency with
that
um
and we still have a great relationship
um to this day so 20 years later now
your life is much better
yes now i mean drastically from three
years ago when i began counseling
um
it's dramatically changed the way that i
can carry myself publicly
and not burn out
um the way i can separate from my
anxiety
the way i can question myself
in
episodes that had previously led up to
the psychogenic non-epileptic seizures
um
because what that is is it's like your
brain
is like short-circuiting like
emotionally you're conscious of it but
you're not controlling it
um
so it's
it's
not
um reappeared since i started counseling
which is saying a lot i mean it's it's
the reasons i was moving each time
because i was losing my mind because it
sounds like social anxiety is like your
biggest hurdle
yeah yeah have you had
relationships
um yeah i was in one serious
relationship had an ex-fiance
[Music]
and
she dealt with a lot of trauma
she didn't have a job she seemed to have
a lot of former lovers that were
stalking them
my ex-fiance's
grandparents seemed to have
supposed ties to the mafia
and like
fraudulent identities i don't know what
was going on with any of it but
having that relationship meant a lot to
me at the time
but there was also a lot that came with
it
um and that ended up
parting ways on um
my
i was uncertain about the relationship
and um
she
cheated on me at one point it was just a
splitting point on it
in your email didn't you mention that
you're still a virgin at this point
that's right
um
yeah i've been intentional about that as
well as
having index addictive tendencies
growing up
um so you're how old i'm 38 38. so i
wanted to
um save myself for marriage i mean i had
um and still do have a genuine
conviction about my position on that
um building into again
that whole paradigm shift for me
spiritually and existentially
speaking um
so i've i've
i've been deliberate about that um
similarly i
with my addictive tendencies um
those run in the family we have
alcoholism uh in our families past and
um
i didn't want any part of that i could
kind of feel it in me um you could see
it in your family
not my
uh immediate family
thankfully
they they cut a different corner in
their life to change that
and i think at the time that was the
best they could do besides our problems
with communication and indirect tension
but do you think if you weren't so
restrained i guess for lack of a better
word maybe you might
lose control oh without a doubt without
a doubt i i used to have rage fits when
i was a kid
just like unbelievable rage like tearing
clothes
um
i would just have like these fits
and
it became like so overwhelming that even
from a young age i realized like i need
to control this i need to get behind
this
before it like destroys me the same with
addictive tendencies
i would binge eat i'd get like cadbury
cream eggs and eat like four full boxes
of them in one sitting
and
that's all i would like ever eat and
i would eat like mcdonald's every day
the same thing every day
i had trash everywhere in my car in my
room
at one point in san francisco when i was
depressed i had like
piss in like five different bottles and
trash strewn over the entire room
um
i was like insanely dysfunctional but um
i could i could play the part well
enough in front of other people but
and along with um severe depression
yeah i mean there would be nothing like
holding me back from taking myself
you know over that edge through
substances
which you've never played around with no
not whatsoever
so and i'm i'm glad for that um
everything i described about
my severe depression
i mean it would just be gasoline on the
fire like it's not as if i had any um
any reason to
to hesitate
um
besides besides
having that presence of mind
that
that that would immediately
take off yeah so you've never had a
drink even irretrievably never well i've
had communion wine once
and
a swig of rum eggnog spontaneously for
no reason at all
so i'm not dogmatic about it yeah do you
feel like you're missing out on anything
by not having sex or
or
indulging in alcohol or anything like
that no and in fact i i think you could
argue that it could enrich your life
yeah absolutely and and i think i think
probably i have a unique perspective
through that in in these things that
people feel like they can't live without
or that are absolute necessity and an
absolute necessity for them
um
[Music]
i'm
i suspect that even finding love
for the right you know and meeting up
matching up with somebody for the right
reasons is probably much easier for you
than
oh i see than if you were having sex
with a lot of people all the time
um
surprisingly surprisingly no you could
see it either way but but but your
social anxiety but to your point still
gets in the way i'm sure right
sure sure but interestingly um
you know girls don't want a hookup but
when they find out you don't want to
have sex until you're married with like
an actual commitment
and trust developed um
then they're not interested it depends
on the girl though it depends on the
girl there's all kinds of girls out
there yeah i mean
and those wouldn't be the kind of girls
that i'd be after anyway so that's right
yeah
yeah people people like to generalize
and say oh yeah
yeah this is how women are this is how
men are and it's like that's that's oh
yeah yeah it's such a blanket statement
entirely yeah it becomes terribly
enacted people stereotype all the time
with that yeah
yeah it's an unusual
stand that you're
taking but you're just doing it to
protect yourself from
losing control and perhaps getting more
depressed and things like that right
yeah
yeah to keep enough separation from my
impulse
um
and to maintain perspective so that back
to your family that there was
what kind of like gambling alcohol
things like that
yeah um my mom's side
um
alcoholism
um
some abuse um
and
her my great-grandfather apparently had
gambled away their house
um
parents side it went and on both sides
actually you know there were these like
unknown relationships of
family members that we didn't know you
know were tied into previous
relationships that went hidden and we
did we didn't know for years and years
ago it was messy for a lot of families
until either they were almost passing
away you know or um someone finally said
something
and do you see this as a
it's a way to
find fulfillment and happiness for you
right taking the stance yeah yeah
absolutely um
again because i'm sure some people would
listen to your story and say how can you
enjoy life but
i could i can see how you could enjoy
life much more this way yeah from the
building blocks existentially speaking
um
it it goes into relationship um into the
creator the source itself the i am
itself itself
um
so
it has everything to do with
relationship and like the purity of that
um
the problem of the human condition
getting to the root of that
so what you're saying about
relationships also pertains to
society as a as a whole right
yeah yeah yeah so
irreducibly speaking existentially
speaking
and then it scales outward um
which in a sense is what i meant by
uh irreducibly and infinitely
um
you know beyond
our finitude infinitely in that sense
but also on its way up um
so
society and communities families on my
channel more than anywhere you see how
many broken families there are out there
yeah exactly which is really the problem
case in point like family is the fabric
of society essentially speaking like
um
it's not that difficult to grasp we're
just so good at
busying ourself uh
like with our own pursuits our own
selfish pursuits
that we remove ourselves from that
responsibility we create like a
mechanism to disown responsibility in
that sense um the family takes the hit
family takes the hit relationships take
the hit um back to what i was saying
about it and in turn the kids and the
next generation take the hit absolutely
and as far as what i was saying about
acting on what you know is right
throwing yourself into it once you know
what you should do
it goes into relationships that we have
and the responsibility that we take the
price that we pay
um a little um excerpt of a poem that i
recently wrote had incur the cost or
suffer the loss
um
we have to
bring the costs upon ourself in a sense
of responsibility
and in the way that we
regard others with respect
um
going back to
love your neighbor as yourself
and
biblically speaking the first
commandment
love the lord your god with all your
heart
as being the first
dealing with the core of relationship
the source of our self
and then scaling that into personal
relationships
and in the same
sense like the old testament um eye for
an eye tooth for a tooth
more in the concept that by harming
someone you are harming yourself
you are tied in community with them
you are part of an organism together
in
um
relationship as a whole and as a
community and individually and
personally
with your maker
all of these things irreducibly and
infinitely speaking
speak of relationship life is defined by
relationship to from with of
out from the silence of the self we
recognize relationship again
irreducibly and infinitely
so
um
it's it's it's worth everything i can
put into it proportionate to my capacity
proportion to anyone's
capacity
um
to experience that relationship restored
which is
the aspect of my belief in christ in
christianity and jesus christ
existentially speaking again it's kind
of from a different frame of view
than i think you're not going to church
um i've kind of went to a couple here
and there i haven't been part of a
church in
over a decade
so it sounds like you're a little bit
obsessive you you said your ocd right
yes
i mean it but it also sounds like you
analyzed deeply what religion means to
you
and rather than finding like a an
existing organized religion that you
could just follow you kind of
ask yourself some questions to figure
out what
what religion is to you right
yeah it's like
this this approach of existentialism is
like a reverse engineering
so
um i am christian i believe in jesus
christ the claims he made the
underpinning principles that
that tie that into this
full picture
but i was
doing a kind of reverse engineering and
alongside that and building up
some of the points i previously
mentioned um
i was also landing on like
that week question
indicates
relationship
um
that we're
we're um measuring life by loss
essentially by our need
um
[Music]
and
uh
so i was just building into these
concepts alongside
actually
eventually reading the bible from a
completely different perspective
when i was miserable enough
to bring myself to reading the bible
basically i i had such a hard time with
reading because i would get
frustrated and locked up it's like my
focus with ocd
would
um out drive what my body could give
to where i would be rigid my eyes would
be dried out my neck would be hurting
hours after being engaged with either
drawing like art that i used to do
or for instance reading so reading was
miserable for me and i reached
low enough a point
funny enough that
i said to myself well
if i don't want to live i might as well
read the bible
like earnestly
and so i would just start with like a
chapter every day only
um and i would repeat that over time
and
that also kind of closed off the anxiety
of how much am i going to read and what
does this mean exactly up front
and so i was pairing
that experience with
the reverse engineering of these
existential questions that i was
creating that i was recognizing
i think i think also something i
recognize in
part of that
is
in the way that we separate ourselves
as i said the subjective being the
vehicle of objectivity and the way that
we have
a
modal removal from the self
i think
um
we're terrified of god
because
god is
perfection god is holy
so
uh that's terrifying to approach um
and
that was something i i recognize going
back into these principles of
existential relationship as it were and
we are not a source unto ourself
what we experience is a gift um
so
but we're not just running on our own
steam i mean we can kid ourselves for a
little while i think we live in hyper
consumerist enough a form of life
that we have a sense of a false sense of
control
and we're very clever about creating
that separation in the same way that we
um deny that we maybe did something that
we know was wrong
we can make a story like different
pathological liars that i've had
crossed paths with in my life different
bosses that kind of thing
um we're very clever to make that
separation
so that's something i was coming to the
ground on
alongside reading
scripture um which filled out my
perspective
in a more enriching way rather than just
hook line sinker
parroting
something you're told to memorize
so i'm kind of an odd man out and and i
get still like all these years later
kind of similar to how i'd grown up
um
but i think a lot of christians are
gaining in perspective a bit
um like possibly
uh by force of change in the world
around them
um and
from the level of things exposed through
like the internet
um
but i i'm still kind of in an odd
position i think there's other people
like me also probably
do you have any regrets in your life
uh regrets sure plenty um so many um
[Music]
i think that was part of the madness for
me um
regret itself not to just dodge the
question but like getting to the root of
it what a question of that is like um
i think that was part of the madness and
my depression all those years ago is
i had so many regrets i was aware that
uh i'm a hypocrite of my own intentions
um
and and i sat with
um the reality of guilt in me
not as an identity of like i'm so
ashamed and i'm like uh
some guilty person or whatever dragging
on like that but
just like at the core
existentially speaking
um yeah plenty of regret um
and again
um
to me it all builds into that
relationship
where
um
there's true fulfillment and growth
beyond that human condition so to speak
yeah i think we're as humans we're meant
to grow and learn
absolutely yeah
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned
in your life um
i would say
when you've sat with something well
enough
to know what you should do
you should throw yourself into it
you should immediately throw yourself
into it before you can calculate how
you're gonna go about it even
um
the times that i moved or
the jobs that i left
the decisions i made and recognized
[Music]
i realized i had
either delayed the decision
or i realized
it wasn't a matter of sticking around
and waiting for the right moment
once you know and relationally speaking
too
if you know something's off make it
right like
once you have sat with something
in your conscience to know what's right
act on it
before you can feel like you're giving
up something
because
at that point you're you're just
treading water you're you're kidding
yourself
so
all right randall thank you so much for
sharing your story
thanks for having me i wish you the best
of luck
thank you very much thanks
you